[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal ein
tutorial wie man türkischen schwarztee
kocht denn im zuge dessen dass wir jetzt
unsere zeit kann endlich haben kamen
ganz auf die nachfrage wie macht man den
türkischen tee ganz traditionell hier im
scheitern wird also in diesem in dieser
teekanne und wir haben auch liebe sarah
und kamerafrau haben wir auch gesagt
hier kannst du mal eines seiner coolen
clubs drehen wie man dem thema der bund
ist im shop da ist auch selber türke und
der markt selber tee und irritiert
zeigen und irgendwie ist da los ist ganz
komisch bekommt und die zubereitung war
gar nicht richtig da hab ich gesagt mir
komm wir machen das ist doch nur als
youtube-video und sind hier werden alle
fragen beantwortet bleibt auf jeden fall
bis zum schluss dran denn es gibt auf
jeden fall noch was zu gewinnen da sich
das unsere mrt kann nach sehr langer
wartezeit über einem jahr endlich da
sind wollten wir euch am ende des videos
auch noch belohnen die tkn sind übrigens
komplett aus emaille also sowohl die
untere große kann man als auch die obere
kleine kann und dadurch ist sie für alle
herdarten geeignet also auch für
induktion ich habe zum beispiel ein
induktionskochfeld aber auf 14 ran
elektro und gas also eine zeit kann also
ein scheitern bequem in zeitnot kann ich
lieb das wort besteht aus zwei kannen
einmal die untere das ist die größere
und die kleinere obere und hier oben
wird quasi ein sehr konzentrierter
schwarzsee gekocht und hier unten
befindet sich später nur wasser aber wir
gehen jetzt erst mal zur zubereitung die
ihr habt euren schwarztee am
aromatischen bekommen so wie ihr euch
auch in türkischen restaurants oder halt
auch eine reise wert wird und ich glaube
jeder von euch hat schon einen
türkischen schwarztee bekommen wenn da
mal in einem türkischen restaurant war
ich habe es gerne meine kommentare ob
die fansite ob die typischen schwarz die
genauso müssen wir und hinterlasst doch
gerne ein abo wenn euch solche tutorials
interessieren und ihr solche basics
öfter sehen möchte ich hab jetzt erstmal
meinen getrockneten schwarztee das ist
ceylon tee ist ganz ganz typisch kann
ich das gerne auch mal final zeigen das
sind nämlich sehr grobe und große
blätter und dann sind auch die
beliebtesten genau das ist jetzt hier
der zweite täter ist extrem aromatisch
und lecker und damit es später nicht
bitter oder trüb wird wird er einmal
unter lauwarmem wasser abgespült und es
ist nicht so dass dann unten drunter ihr
dunkles wasser raus kommt sondern es
wird wirklich einfach nur für ein paar
sekunden abgespielt das ist erstmal in
step eins ganz ganz wichtig so und der
abgespielte schwarztee kommt jetzt hier
oben rein es gibt eine faustformel wobei
jeder mag ihn ja auch anders
konzentriert die einen mögen es ein
bisschen dunkler die an ein bisschen
heller komme ich gleich noch darauf
zurück aber so als faustformel finde ich
mal so ein esslöffel pro person optimal
so eigentlich gibt es hierfür kein
richtiges rezept in jeder macht es nach
gefühlt aber für die blutigen anfänger
erkläre ich jetzt wirklich extrem extrem
kleinlich und schritt für schritt da
kommt zwar ein esslöffel getrockneter t
pro person aber gleich kommt es noch
darauf an wie viel wasser ihr hier oben
in die kanne gibt weil wie gesagt dass
es eher so dass der konzentrierte t und
er wird dann später aufgeführt mit
wasser wir brauchen jetzt aber erst mal
das wasser also lassen wir die obere
keine kurz beiseite und füllen die
hierauf gerne bis zu drei viertel mit
wasser und dann lassen wir das ganze
erst einmal aufkochen
[Musik]
das wasser in den unteren kanne konnte
jetzt aufkochen stufe acht von 90
genommen ist hat nur ein paar minuten
gedauert rom ist nach wie vor nur unser
ausgewaschen at drin und jetzt machen es
folgendes wir nehmen uns den das
ausgekochte wasser mit dem ich noch
hallo wie gesagt es gibt ja kein rezept
dafür daher auf jeden fall das wasser
erst mal bis dahin füllen des dt
komplett bedeckt ist und dann könnt ihr
euch vorstellen kommt noch mal die
doppelte menge an wasser dazu das heißt
das wasser steht am ende ca 3 cm über
dem team so hier fehlt uns ja jetzt eine
erhebliche wassermenge und wir möchten
ja auch lange von unserem tee genießen
daher wird jetzt noch mal mit wasser
aufgefüllt und dann wird das ganze noch
mal aufgekocht und ziehen gelassen
[Musik]
so jeder tee hat ja eine bestimmte zeit
beim schwarztee zum thema acht bis zwölf
minuten das ist aber auch
geschmackssache ich bin immer so bei
zehn minuten jetzt gehe ich hier
nochmals stufe ganz entspannt stufe 7
von 9 denn ob das wasser jetzt aufkocht
innerhalb von zwei minuten oder
innerhalb von fünf sechs und es kommt ja
auch immer auf einem herd an wie schnell
der ist derzeit beträgt er trotzdem ca
10 minuten oder wenn der mieter hat auch
zwölf es ist wie gesagt geschmackssache
der tee wird je länger er steht immer
ein bisschen stärker und natürlich könnt
ihr auch immer wieder ein bisschen
wasser von der unteren kante in die
obere kante gehen und noch ein tipp an
der stelle sollte das wasser hier unten
abkühlt einfach wegschütten oder hier
gießt blumenmeer mit das mache ich immer
ganz gerne oder die kräuter da hinten
und dann könnt ihr neues wasser offen
und das nochmal erneut hochkochen lassen
weil sonst habt ihr geschmackliche
einbußen und nachdem ist dann einmal
auch gekochtes das was da könnt ihr
wieder runter auf stufe 3 von 9 und dann
das ganze ganz entspannt ziehen lassen
unser ziel ist fertig wir können jetzt
servieren und das macht man in dem man
erst mal aus der oberen kanne den
konzentrierten schwarztee in ein
typisches tigers füllt und dann fühlt
man quasi mit dem wasser auf und da gibt
es unterschiede das ist jetzt relativ
agip das bedeutet also mich sehr start
und wer als dunkler markt also stärker
das ist ein scoyo da braucht ihr dann
einfach nur ein bisschen mehr von den
konzentrierten schwarztee 1 ich bin bei
kaffee zum beispiel gar keinen zucker
viel mehr aber was schwarztee angeht mag
es einfach wenn die süße damit drin ist
daher kommt bei mir zum beispiel noch
ein bisschen zucker mit rein wenn man
dann ganz traditionell würfelzucker oder
es gibt auch viele die mögen es dann
einfach pur denkt dran schwarztee
enthält koffein daher vielleicht dreimal
überlegen ob man den arm zum neu nur
noch trinkt wobei an langen wochenenden
und wo man nicht sofort ins bett muss
trinke ich den auch schon mal sehr spät
einfach um den abend ausklingen zu
lassen
gerade so im sommer abends wenn man dann
beisammen sitzt gerne auch morgens zum
frühstück das ist ja ganz typisch dass
man morgens dann zum frühstück genießen
ich habe hier zum beispiel heute ist sie
mit gemacht dass in diese typischen
sesamkringel rezept ist entweder
komplett online passt auch ist ein
perfekter match also ich hoffe das video
hat euch gefallen falls ihr noch weitere
fragen haben schreibt sie gerne hier
unten die kommentare und jetzt kommt's
mir versprochen noch ein gewinnspiel und
zwar könnt ihr je eine rose bzw arthrose
abstrakt teekanne von uns gewinnt und
eine weiß abstraktion her das design ist
übrigens von hamza mir persönlich also
die gibt so nirgends und wir haben es
selbst design ich finde es muss halt
einfach mal was anderes und was ganz
besonderes wie macht ihr mit abonniert
meinen kanal hinterlasst diesem video
einen daumen nach oben und kommentiert
einfach wo ihr den ersten schwarz die
getrunken habt oder was sie mit
schwarztee verbindet falls sie noch kein
schwarze probiert habe dann schreibt
einfach rein dass sie gerne mal
probieren möchte wieder schmeckt und das
ganze natürlich mit unseren kann und
gerne auch euren favorit also welche
farbe ihre favorisierte einschreiben
oder low sich innerhalb von einer woche
aus und kontakte wie gewinner und
ansonsten setze ich euch den link in der
infobox auf wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel
spaß zum nachmachen und sage es zunächst
einmal chilis oder kita
[Musik]